[Musique]
deux mille sept cent vingt participants
pour une course devenue mythique le
départ de la diagonale des fous été
donné à saint pierre devant un public
venu nombreux encourager ces milliers
des très longs et courts stimulera le
rider sur les plus beaux sentiers de
notre hymne 166km 9611 m de dénivelé
compose essentiellement des espaces
naturels sensibles propriété du
département à 2720 raider qui s'engagent
dans les sentiers de la réunion
je ne peux que les encourager les
féliciter ou à voir ce bout de l'effort
et le département accompagne bien sûr le
grand raid à notre façon en entretenant
les sentiers de randonnée et donc il est
important pour moi de manquer enfin le
soutien du conseil départemental à cette
belle manifestation du grand raid
félicitations aux organisateurs au
président chico et bien sûr que le
meilleur gagne mais je dis toujours que
ce qui est important aussi c'est de
participer
comme le disait si bien pierre de
coubertin donc 2720 au départ
combien l'arrivée je ne le sais pas on
verra mais en tout cas bravo à celles et
ceux qui se sont engagés dans cette 27e
édition du grand raid
bravo une course mais avant tout un défi
avec une seule et unique volonté aller
au bout de soi même est arrivée dans les
temps au stade de la redoute
ils sont plusieurs à vouloir relever ce
pari complètement fou
j'adore comment l'année dernière
ça s'est bien passé mon dieu j'ai quitté
vers le travail de deux patients se
déplie personnel voilà c
c'est arrivé
dieu
citation à de partir et d'appréhension
en même temps parce que c'est l'inconnu
une partie que
services connaît pas le débat voilà on
verra bien c'est un challenge personnel
j'ai déjà fait la mascareignes en 2015
sera libre ou en 2016 et là j'avais
envie de me mesurer aux grands formats
donc 165 kilomètres je pense que ça va
me ça va me suffire je pense tiennent
comme une pression pour le départ parce
que la difficulté est grande
c'est une course mondialement reconnue
donc oui je pense que ea com une fois de
plus la diagonale des fous ne faillit
pas à sa réputation
on pose difficile qui attire des
milliers de participants venus des
quatre coins du monde
une aubaine tant d'autres mais c'est
magnifique cirque hôpitaux classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
le vainqueur devrait franchir la ligne
d'arrivée vendredi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]